my my father was a guess he was getting
his master's degree in chemistry at
Columbia and he died when I was two and
then my mom was a single parent raising
an only child in the 60s and the 70s and
she was a frustrated painter and
musician you know she wanted to be a
painter she want to be a musician but
she had to do sort of menial labor just
to pay the rent and she was also like
all of her friends went off and became
hippies so I think she felt she was that
she was a little bummed out that she
couldn't go move to San Francisco and
join the hippie revolution so yes she
was a frustrated artist basically one of
the things I'm most grateful for is that
I did grow up in a creative family you
know my mom even though she did menial
labor was you know she was a great
painter and a really great musician my
uncle was photographer my other uncle is
a sculptor both my answer writers my
great grandmother taught classical
composition my grandmother grandmother
was a watercolor painter so everyone my
family had some sort of creative outlet
and so is just assumed that I would do
something creative like I really think
that my mother and the people my family
would have been very disappointed if I
decided to become a bond trader you know
so if anything even though I grew up in
a very conservative suburban environment
I was always encouraged to do creative
things
you